hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
word search two and once again like
usual this is a problem from the blind
75 link code list
a list that we've been tracking on this
spreadsheet and the link will be in the
description to this
and we are very close actually to being
done with all the major problems on this
list
that i wanted to do and probably at some
point i will finish up some of these
easy ones like contains duplicates i
think that's a pretty trivial problem
don't know how many people are waiting
for a solution on that one but i
probably will do it eventually
just for the sake of completeness so
this is word search 2 and word search 1
actually we already solved on this
channel and that is leak code 79 so i do
recommend understanding that problem
before you try to do this one because
this is definitely an extension of that
one
so we are given an m by n board exactly
the same as we were in
in word search one and we are given a
list of words this time
previously we were just given a single
word but in this case we're given a
list of words and we want to know from
that list of words
which of those words exist in this board
and whichever ones do exist we want to
return those words
so previously we only wanted to know if
one word
existed in here or not so we returned
true or false
but in this case we want to know how
many or exactly which of these words do
exist
so if we just reuse our solution from
the first word search
what we're gonna do is we're gonna go to
every single position
in this grid and we're gonna start a
depth first search recursively on here
so it's just
backtracking right we're gonna be
checking brute force
what's every word we could come up with
right so starting at
o could we come up with a word in our
list of words right so we just go in
every
all four directions basically right so
if we go here we'll get oe
if we go this way we'll get oa right
etcetera etcetera we could
you know possibly make a word like this
o a a n
or we could make a word like this o a t
h
and this happens to be a word in our
list of words
so we would return we would say okay o a
t h this is a word so this is going to
be added to our solution set
so it's going to go in the output so a
very brute force approach would be so
for every single word we're gonna run a
depth first search
starting at every single position and
check okay could we make the word
oath starting from here could we make
the word oath
starting from here etc etc until we get
you know all the way
to the bottom of the grid and we have
run a depth first search on every single
position now that's not going to be
super efficient right
and then we're going to have to do the
exact same thing for the next word p
right because maybe this word could
exist so we'd have to brute force check
every single position etc etc etc
and one way to analyze the time
complexity of that would be something
like
worst case four and four because that's
the number of directions
you know from a any position we could go
we could go in four directions now we
can't revisit the same
position twice of course so basically
the length of our depth for search is
going to be the dimensions of the board
let's call that m by
n right so that's how much one dfs would
be and we're going to be doing a dfs
starting at every single position so
it's going to be something like
m by n to the power or and by n
multiplied
by 4 to the power of m n and we're going
to be doing this for every single word
so basically let's say w is the number
of words so this is going to be super
inefficient now there is a way basically
where we can make this more efficient
where we can get rid of this constant w
basically
the solution is going to be we're only
going to have to run dfs
starting from each position a single
time because
as we're checking you know what are all
the words we can create
starting at this position right starting
at this character a
what are all the words that we could
create now the main idea that we're
going to be doing instead of
just checking a single word at a time
like running dfs on here just to check
if this word exists
let's check simultaneously let's check
all the words in our set
which of them can be created starting at
this position so that's the idea we're
going to be using
and we're going to be using a data
structure which is going to be very
useful for it because what we're going
to notice is we can
check all words starting at here based
on the prefix right so
clearly here we only want words starting
with the letter
a right so the prefix is going to be a
and
what kind of data structure can help us
organize these words
based on their prefix guess what
either you have heard of this data
structure before or you haven't if you
haven't heard of this data structure
then you probably don't have a chance of
solving this problem in the optimal way
so i would learn what this data
structure is first but if you do already
know it
the solution is actually not too bad to
implement so this
the data structure we're going to be
using is a try aka
a prefix tree which is going to help us
organize these words based on their
prefixes
so let's say we had a pretty small grid
and we had a pretty small list of words
the words are
app ape and ace so we want to know which
of these words can be found
inside of this grid now let's use the
idea of prefixes that i mentioned so
let's say we're going to start our dfs
here right so this is the first position
we're going to be at and we can't
revisit
this position twice makes sense so far
so so far we have a single character
right
we have found the character a right so
we can basically we want to know all the
words that we could create starting at
this position dfs from here and of
course then we're going to repeat that
by doing a dfs from here
here and here but we're so far we're
only starting here
and of our entire list of words we want
to know which one of them
have a prefix of a because
if you know if we had a word such as
bat then we'd say okay bat does not
start with an a so basically we don't
even have to consider that right we
don't have to run a dfs on here
searching for the word bat it doesn't
even exist in this position
right the letter b does not start here
so what we're gonna have to do is
basically go through every single word
this word starts with an a
this word starts with an a this word
starts with an a so potentially
so far all of the words could be
found starting at this position right so
we haven't eliminated any of these just
yet
so now let's say we go down first right
of course if we go
up that's out of bounds so you know
we're just going to return there because
we're going to see okay
the it ended with the the word a a does
not exist in our list of words so of
course we're not gonna do that of course
if we went left
that also would not work but we can go
down so let's
start going down first so we add a p to
our word so far so so far we have ap so
then again we're going to just go
through every single word check okay
does this start with ap
yes does this start with ap yes does
this start with ap
no so so we don't want to consider this
word anymore right but as you can see
this is going to get kind of complicated
right
we're having to go through the list of
words every single time that's not
really helping us out in terms of
efficiency
a more intuitive way would be if we
could check the prefixes of these words
more easily and of course we know a data
structure prefix tree
is exactly what that is for so basically
what a prefix tree is going to be it's
going to be
you know every single character is going
to be a node so one node is going to be
a
and we're just going to take these words
and add them to our prefix tree so
we want all words starting with the
character a to go
here right so let's add childs of these
so what characters come after a
of course we have a p and then we have a
c so
all words that start with a p are going
to go down here
and all words that start with a c are
gonna go down here
and how many different words do we have
that start with ap we have
uh app and we have ape
and all words that start with ac is just
one word
ace so do you see how this is this tree
is organizing these words based on the
prefixes
so now we started at a right we want all
words that start at a so so this is
where we're going to be at so far and we
see that
of course there are three words that
start with
a and by the way let's say ap
this is not a word even though it is a
path in our tribe because basically
let's just say we call
these three leaf nodes happen to be the
end of words it's possible that we could
have a word ap
but in this case we don't up here right
we don't have ap
so this this node is not going to be
marked as the end of a word
so only these three are marked as end of
words but so now when we go down in this
direction we go to a p
all we're going to do from this position
is check does this have a child p
if it does we're going to say okay let's
go there so now this is going to be all
words
that potentially start with ap so this
prefix
now if we did not have a p right then we
would say okay
we went down here ap we don't have any
words
that start with ap so in that case we
would just return that's our base case
right if we didn't have any words with a
prefix of ap
which we could check pretty easily with
this prefix tree
we wouldn't want to continue going down
this direction
so you can see that we're making things
a lot more efficient for us using this
try
so now from p we can't go down that's
out of bounds we can't go left
we can't go up because we already
visited that position so we can go
right which is going to add the
character e so from here from this p we
want to check do we have a child
e well this is not the e this is though
right
okay so so far we we did find a path
in our prefix tree now let's check is
this the end of a word since it's marked
purple that's what i'm just indicating
so yes this is the end of a word
therefore we found a single word down
this path that we were maintaining
called a p e that yes you can see it's
found in our list of words
so therefore we found one word that we
can make from this grid
that you know can be found basically so
we're going to add
ape to our results now from here
we would want to continue now we can't
go right we can't go down we can't go
left because we already visited there so
we would go
up so we'd say okay add a c right so
from here
a p e a p e and then we add a c
does this word exist well this does not
have a child of c
so of course we can't do that and that
makes sense because this word apec
does not exist in our input list of
words so therefore at this point we
would return because we don't even have
any words that start with this prefix
so so far we did find one word ape now
when we started here the first
direction we went was down but it's
possible we could also go right so let's
do that so
now we have ac so we started here we
check does this have a child c yes it
does it's over here right so now we
can't go right we can't go up we can't
go back left so
now we go down a c e do we have a e
child
under this c yes we do and this is the
end of a word right it exists in our
list of input words so now we found
another word
ace and then we would continue from our
grid in the only
position we can go to which is the p
right so we'd add a p we'd say okay does
this e have a child
p it does not so therefore we can't
continue so that's going to be our base
case
but it's okay because we at least found
one word so we can go ahead and add that
to
our list of words ape and ace so now is
going to be the easy part so we we
started our dfs from this position now
let's start the dfs
from c so we look in our prefix tree we
do have
a prefix starting at a do we have a
prefix starting at c
we don't so immediately we can say okay
we know for sure
none of our words start with the
character c we didn't
we didn't just have to we didn't have to
run through the list of words to do that
we just did that
in an o of one operation we just checked
do any
is our root node does our root node have
a child
c it does not so therefore none of the
words
start with a c so we don't even have to
continue the dfs from this position
and you can tell that's the same is
going to happen for the character e
none of the words start with e we don't
have an e root node in our prefix tree
similarly p we don't have any root node
p in other words start with p
so so we're not going to find any
additional words in
this grid we only found two words ape
and ace
we found ape and ace we did not find app
so we're going to return these two words
as a
list so once you kind of understand that
this problem can be solved by the prefix
tree
and you know how to implement a prefix
tree and you know how to implement
backtracking dfs which you can learn
from word
or word search one this problem is not
too difficult
so now let's write the code so the first
thing i want to do is actually implement
a try node
class or a try class basically and so
in the constructor of this if you have
written a try
before you'll know that there are mainly
two things that we worry about for a try
node and that
is its list of children so that's going
to be one member
variable for this class a list of
children now you could use a list in
this case
all characters i think are going to be
from lower case a to z but a more
generic way to handle it is just using a
hash map
so the key is going to be the character
and the value in this hash map is going
to be the child
node the child tri node and also for
each
node you want to be able to mark if it
is the end of a word or not so
one member variable for is word it's
going to be a boolean initially we can
set it to false
now to our try we are going to want to
add words to it so let's define one
function add word
and this is really going to be the only
function so we'll be passed in a string
a word and we just want to add that word
to our try
so let's get our current pointer to be
at the
root node which is just the self node
and then we're gonna go character by
character in this word and just start
adding them
now it's possible that the the character
might not exist in our tri node if it
does not exist so if c
not in current dot children if this
character does not exist then we're
going to obviously have to insert it
so current.children at character c we
want to create a try node for this
particular character
if it already exists then we're going to
skip this if statement and simply we're
just going to
move our current pointer to that
position so current.children
at character c so that's the try node
that we want and at the end all we have
to do is return the current pointer
or actually not return the current
pointer at the end we have to mark that
this is now going to be the end of the
word so the last character that we ended
at
current is word we want to set that to
true
when we insert a word now the reason
we're not going to define a search
function like searching a word in this
trinode is because we're going to be
doing that
simultaneously as we do our depth first
search on the
board so now let's start getting into
the dfs
we're actually the first thing we're
going to want to do is create a root
tri-node
so so let's create a trinode with the
class that we just defined and
for every word that we're given in the
input so for w in the list of words we
just want to go ahead and take
each word and add it to our try so root
dot add
word w and now we can start going ahead
and doing the depth first search so
first i like to do is get the dimensions
of the board so rows and columns
we can get the length of the board we
know for sure that the board is going to
be non-empty and
the list of words is going to be
non-empty as well they do tell us that
in the problem description
now i'm going to create two sets result
and visit so result
is going to be the set of words it's
possible we could visit
the same word twice inside of our board
so we don't want to have to
return duplicates and the visit set is
pretty self-explanatory when we run a
dfs
on the board we don't want to get stuck
in like an infinite loop or mainly
we don't want to repeat the same
character twice we're not allowed to do
that
so once we have those defined we are
going to define a dfs
recursive function we're going to be
going through every position so we want
to pass in the coordinates row column as
the coordinates
we want to pass in the current node that
we're at
in our try you know depending on what
characters we've already visited before
and we also want to pass in what is the
word so far so for example you know we
visited two characters ac
we want that to be stored in this word
variable and of course if the node that
we're visiting happens to be the end of
a word what we're going to do is just
take that word and add it to our result
which is out here we don't have to pass
it into every recursive call
so for this dfs let's go ahead and
define the base cases so of course if we
go out of bounds
row is less than 0 or column is less
than zero
or row is too big meaning it's the
number of rows
or a column is too big meaning it's the
number of columns or
maybe this position row column is
already been visited so if it's already
in visit then we're going to return
or maybe the character that we're at for
example
board at position row column maybe
this character is not even in
our try maybe it's in bounds right but
it's
not even in our try at the current
position that we're at
in our try node right meaning this
character
is not in node.children
right if it's not in the children of the
current node that we're visiting that
means this character doesn't exist in
our tribe therefore
it's not one of the words that we were
given in our input list of words so
if any of these are true then we're
going to return that's our base case if
that's not true first thing we want to
do is make sure we mark
this position as visited and after
after we're done the last thing we do
before we return is we're going to have
to
mark this as unvisited basically since
this
is backtracking uh we we can't visit the
same one twice but once we're no longer
done visiting it after we return
then we can go ahead and you know remove
this position from being visited
so since we got to a new character we
want to update some variables so we want
to update
node so node is going to be set to
node.children
of the current character that we just
visited which is board
at position rc so we're updating the
node because we know that that node does
exist
and we're updating the word right so
we're taking the current word
adding to it the new character that we
just reached
board at rc and before we do the
recursive case again before we look at
the neighboring positions we do want to
check is this the end of a word so we
can check that based on our node so if
node is word
is true then of course we can take our
result
and add to it the word that we just
built right the string
itself not the node we're not going to
add the node to result we're going to
have the string
word so this is just basically you know
checking if it actually is a word
in our list of words and we're you know
doing some uh bookkeeping here
and once that is done we can go ahead
and actually do our recursive case
you could write it with a loop but i
like to be lazy and i think it's pretty
okay to just copy and paste
dfs four times so we're gonna pass in
the coordinates and we're gonna pass in
the node and we're going to pass in the
word that so far we have built
so let's just copy and paste this four
times going in each of the four
directions
up down left right so all that we have
defined our dfs function about 15 lines
of code so remember what we actually
want to do with that dfs is go through
every single
position every single starting position
in the grid so i'm going to do
a quick 2d loop a quick nested loop on
the entire
grid and call dfs from
each starting position in the grid now
for node what are we going to pass in
we're going to pass in our root node
that we defined up above and for the
word
initially it's going to be empty right
so that's what we're going to pass in
for the word
once that is all said and done we want
to return our result but don't forget
our result
is a set to eliminate duplicates we can
cast it into a
list pretty easily in python so that's
what i'm going to do
as you can see this is the entire code
so this
is the entire code and all of its glory
you can see that this solution does work
once or twice it actually did give me
time limit expire i think there is a
slight
optimization that you can make to this
problem i don't think it actually
improves the overall time complexity
but once you find a word in the try
basically what you can do is actually
remove
that if it's a leaf node you can remove
that
from the try because you don't want to
have to you don't have to search for the
same word twice that's a slight
optimization that you can make but i
but i think this solution is mainly good
enough and it's too big to even
fit on the screen that's how you know
this is a hard problem no matter what
you do it's going to be a lot of code
that you have to write
but i hope that this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching